[Music]
um what's up friends welcome back to
culture binge the wisecrack podcast
where we spread
our wings and fly through the cultural
zeitgeist i'm your host michael burns
joined as always
by a woman who refuses to come on this
podcast unless i take
and fail a drug test twice a month
serbia
and our special guest someone who's
repeatedly told me that i won't get the
music she likes because i was born in
the 80s
helen flourish helen and serbi how are
we today
doing very well how are you good it was
exciting to just organically do that
introduction without any preparation it
felt good
um we have a lot to talk about today uh
including
the olympic committee being an
insufferable group of narcs
um growing generational divides showing
up on tick-tock
and we got a special segment with our
friend alec you might be wondering where
is alec
he'll he'll be here in a second so just
hold on that'll be our third segment
today but first
we want to say a special hello to helen
flores thank you so much for joining us
thank you for having me i am just
honored to be
in the presence of you know cultural
icons here so thank you
yeah well people probably know helen if
you
regularly consume wisecrack videos if
you
for some reason and this is cool too
prefer podcast
and do not like to watch our videos you
might not be as
familiar with helen so so helen how long
have you been doing stuff
in the wisecrack extended universe
oh man i think it's been three years
actually so i started out
uh back a few years ago with writing
some
some pieces on some videos rather on
kind of the intersection between science
and pop culture from there i started
hosting
and now that's mostly what i do although
i'd really like to get back into writing
again
so maybe we can make that happen
sometimes i know some people
um i know a bunch of people i know i'm
one of the people
um and and what is the where does the
science come from i think of you helen
as
a science person without really knowing
why you're a science person or what your
or your background is but i just always
think that if there's a science question
i could ask you and whatever you say
will be canonically true
so where does the where does the science
i mean
yeah i'll do my best to make up answers
to any questions that you have
um i am so so basically
i studied neuroscience in college um at
that time i was trying to figure out if
i wanted to go to med school or not you
know big
pressing questions but i was really
interested in
neuroscience and media and the way that
you know media
affects the brain the way that you know
the things we think
ultimately affect the kind of media that
we create and um i was trying to try and
decide if i wanted to go down the
academic route like you did burns or if
i wanted to go down the practical route
and see if i could you know
maybe create content with some of these
ideas that i had
and i chose the latter after going to
way too much school and accumulating too
much student debt like a good millennial
so um yeah so i've got you know taken
one for the generation
um but yeah so that's that's my
background and um so i went to
i actually went to journalism school at
usc and um that's
from there i got involved with wisecrack
a couple years after graduating
so here we are now so nice a real
scientist and a real journalist on the
show this is intimidating
um leveling us so much i know i feel
i feel intimidated i don't think so
actually i feel like i'm just kind of
like a um
just like a faux version of both of
those things like the knockoff version
of them
but i think it adds to my to my brand
you know that's how i know you're a
millennial because you have imposter
syndrome that's one of
and we'll talk about generational stuff
later but i don't know and
you talked about your brand
[Laughter]
yes for sure for sure because like a gen
z person would never think they have a
brand
or sorry a gen x person and a gen z
person would
not even get that there's a split
between their brand and themselves
but a millennial still has the the sense
to or the ability to think that they
have a self and they are a brand
but we'll talk about this more later
because we're getting a generational
divides um but helen we're so glad
you're here today
um you know say hi in the chat but now
we're gonna get into a segment that i'm
gonna be honest we're thinking of maybe
killing
so let us know in the chat or emails
if you like this segment or not i'm just
curious we're not definitely going to
kill it i'm just curious about how we
feel about
slaps and chaps the time where we talk
about stuff we're really excited about
and stuff that we kind of don't like so
serbia let's start with you what are
your slaps and chaps this week
everything chaps this week there's a lot
of change and i'm not great with change
i'm very change reverse so it's very
difficult for me
um to handle that so i'm trying to
stay calm and just try to be a duck let
the water just roll off my back
um and then the one thing that really
slaps so hard is that helen's here
i have loved watching her on the main
channel all these years
um and jared has always said you're
lovely
so i i'm so excited to see you
oh man thank you i mean can i go to my
slaps and chaps because
obviously a slap is that i'm here with
you guys
and i feel like it's a natural segue um
but i'm just going to jump into it
actually unless michael has any
any objection helen what are your slaps
in chats there we go gotta do the intro
yeah so slaps are obviously that i'm
doing this podcast again thank you guys
so much for having me
and serbia seriously same fan girling so
hard
um you just are awesome seriously on the
podcast and
is it because i talked about penis
cookies last time yes it was the penis
cookies which i really um so i was
living in san francisco
if like up until a couple months ago and
i'm like oh how did i miss the penis
cookies i know
i know and they have badge cookies oh my
gosh i'm so excited question
aren't the penis cookies and vag cookies
discussed in a segment that's airing at
the end of this episode
no no we did it last time and then and
then we
did a part two for the second okay i'm
sorry
i just i'm constantly thinking about
penis and vagina cookies so i assume
they're just everywhere all the time
my bad but we weren't recording though
that was like off air when we were
talking about that
now everyone knows we're just constantly
talking about
genital confectionaries so that's that's
my bad
i mean it was no um and it was inspiring
like
i'm gonna have to go find those cookies
um but yeah thank you again and then um
some other some other things that slap
so i recently
went back to tennessee where i grew up
and hung out with my family
for the first time in a long time um
it's weird there's still that like
you guys know that awkward kind of i'm
coming back out into the world phase
that we're all going through because of
the pandemic
yeah it's it's actually real with family
too i'm like i can't figure out like do
i
hug you still i think you know we came
from the same
womb but i don't know how you feel about
hugs anymore but no i think um
yeah so hung out with them and tennessee
that was great and um
got my mom into the great british bake
off so that was awesome
um and i watched a documentary that i
highly recommend i'm sure some people
who are watching this podcast have seen
it
and maybe you guys have too um this 2004
documentary called baraka directed by
ron frick
um written by constantine and genevieve
nicholas so
what it is is basically um it's just
kind of explores
visually humanity right and it's there's
no narration whatsoever
there's just a lot of really fantastic
uh music
and um it's just kind of just takes you
visually
uh with some really outstanding
cinematography they actually built a
custom camera to film this documentary
and um highly highly recommend it won't
go into too many more details but
yeah it's awesome check out baraka um
and as for chaps yeah what do you hate
what makes you mad what sucks right now
the delta variant the delta variant
is it's chap in my ass
as as the science correspondent should
we be how
how should we feel about it because i'll
be honest and this is a bit of a
digression but i think it's important
i go from some days being like oh the
delta variant is scary and bad
but then other days i'll see people i
fall on social media who are like
science people
be like hey dummies here's a graph that
shows you that no one is dying
and the there might be an uptick in
hospitalizations but it's largely
amongst unvaccinated people so it's
really not that big of a deal and this
is becoming endemic anyway so chill out
so can you just tell us and all of our
listeners how we should feel so we don't
have to think for ourselves
yes yeah so it's interesting we spend
different
we have different um science spheres
mine is a lot more um
alarmist i think which which is actually
i think a
consequence of me being a hypochondriac
in general i feel like
the algorithm feat knows that right so
it's gonna feed me
alarmist things but anyway um i
you know i'm obviously not a virologist
and i'm not actually
a scientist i feel so but um i think
i mean for me personally
what's scary about it to me is that you
know we obviously we're all taking
guidance based on the information that's
out there
and a lot of the guidance you know these
these numbers that we get
say that the vaccines are 94
effective against the delta variant
these are you know this information
comes out of a phase in the pandemic
where people are still
you know at home mostly right so that's
you know once we get the information
from what it's like when everything
opens up and people
are out in the real world to me that's
more valid
as far as knowing you know say like
whether or not how how effective are the
vaccines really how afraid should we be
i personally am going to keep wearing my
mask indoors especially after the data
came out
from israel not in my comfort in my own
home but you know in public spaces
um but just because uh like i said i'm a
hypochondriac
and the numbers make me nervous so
i mean i
later this month and i don't even i
don't want to i don't feel comfortable
now i don't feel comfortable going on
the plane i don't feel comfortable being
at a large
uh family event indoors like it makes me
very very uncomfortable the idea of
everybody flying
and being in the same place even though
even though like i'm vaccinated i know
majority of my family's vaccinated i
just
the whole thing just totally freaks me
out and even if i don't die or get
hospitalized like what if there are
long-term effects from it
that's what freaks me out too wow
so um that's the podcast we're all gonna
put masks on and just stop now
and go into bunkers so we'll see you
soon
um no but that's thanks for sharing that
i'm but i'm freaked i'm a little freaked
now i'm a little freaked about that
um but you know part of me just thinks
with all this and i promise
we'll stay right out of this because
it's because we got topics to talk about
but
yeah part of me is a little just annoyed
we never just kept normalized wearing
masks and doors because it's kind of
easy
so just sort of like with everything
happening and like getting back to
normal it's like we could just do that
and make that a normal thing that we do
for a little bit i guess on the flip
side it's like when does it end but
i don't know just seems not that hard
especially if you have like fun masks
like order ones that have patterns you
like and make you excited then you're
fun
it's fun to wear them i still want that
kate middleton
floral mask everyone send find it
send it to serby we'll talk about it at
the end we'll tell you where to find her
we need to get served that mask hashtag
get serbie that mask so real quick i'll
do my slaps and chaps and then we'll
head into things
um slaps if you listen to this podcast
you know that i like
live music and events um going to my
first live concert between now
and the next culture binge it's in an
outdoor venue in a pretty place and not
so big so i think it'll be a good like
getting my toes back into that water but
i'm excited i'm hoping that i'm like
positively overwhelmed by the existence
of live music again
so that's great my chap i guess will
relate to what we're talking about
everyone i know is like traveling now or
going to see family kind of like you
know helen just did serbia's talking
about this
i just don't want to get on a goddamn
plane it doesn't sound fun
airports don't sound fun um sadly i live
far enough away from all of my family
where driving's not
really an option because it would take
days and days
because they live in another shot of the
country so i'm just like kind of not
excited about that and
it seems like it's going to be a busy
travel season and i just imagine sitting
on a plane near a bunch of strangers and
freaks
and it makes me feel bad so that's
that's mine
and i will second my chaps with our bud
due to bides
um his chaps is that his car is pretty
much out of commission due to needing a
part for repairs which take weeks to
month
that sucks dude abides cars suck i hate
cars they make me mad
i'm sorry that your car is broken let's
invent cars that don't break
scientists do it okay now before we
actually get into our uh
our topics this week just a reminder
like subscribe
review rate all those sorts of things we
love it we appreciate it
please do it um and as always if you're
gonna review the podcast
feel feel free to do something fun with
it you know tell us what we would all be
in a certain categorization of things
and helen's here this week so feel free
to do that with helen and we'll get into
some of those
later but now that we're here ready to
get started
we've taken the long way around but now
we're going to get into it
serbia i'm excited to hear what you
think about this topic it's a topic that
makes me very mad i was ranting about
this topic while walking down the street
last night so if you were
near me in los angeles last last night
you could have heard me yelling about
this
what's going on with shikari richardson
an amazing
us track and field athlete and her lack
of inclusion on the olympic team
okay so shikari richardson is
an american sprinter who blazed through
the women's 100 meter trial to make the
team for
the tokyo olympics uh so just as an
aside i love the olympics since
i take let me take the whole time off
usually for work um
and just sit and watch it all day long
anyway uh so after the race
uh shikari and all the other competitors
they took a
routine drug check and officials found
that she had marijuana in her system
which is a banned substance
so you like
many other people might be wondering why
shikari would have used a banned
substance
so close to the olympic games well last
month
while she was competing in oregon which
is a state
with a legal recreational use
where marijuana is legal for
recreational use she was competing
at the us trials and a reporter
told her that her biological mother had
died
and she wasn't expecting this she was
completely blindsided by the news
um and this was just a couple days i
think before
before the trial before the trials were
supposed to start so
she smoked marijuana took to cope with
this loss
and as a result of this positive uh test
result
she received a 30-day suspension
and her victory from the 100 meter uh
sprint was disqualified and her last
hope of
competing in the olympics was to make
the team for the 4x100
relay um and the reason why she would be
able to join
this race is that the relay was
was scheduled after her 30-day
suspension would end so she could have
been named to the team
however the coaches had already selected
the members of the relay squad and had
informed those runners before the test
result became public
and then they decided it would be unfair
to take a slot away from one of those
runners and give it to shikari
because it would be the only way for her
to get onto the team
so after this all happened her
suspension kicked off a debate about
marijuana
and sports and many people said that
marijuana is not a performance
enhancing drug if anything it is the
opposite
um it could make her slower and other
people said rules are rules
um others said that this is another
example of systemic racism
and uh the u.s track and field expressed
sympathy to
shakari and they called for an
investigation
excuse me a re-evaluation of the
anti-doping rules
on marijuana use um
so i'm very much uh in burns's camp
i think that this situation is is very
distressing and ridiculous
um but i want to pass it off to the two
of you to talk a little bit more about
it
what do you think about this situation
do you think that
marijuana should be on the list of
banned substances
alongside other performance enhancing
drugs that usually make
athletes stronger faster or have more
endurance
considering marijuana does none of those
things
yeah i mean it's just it's ridiculous
that they would put marijuana
consumption
on the same playing field as like blood
doping or steroids
or things that have a physical effect of
making your
ability to process oxygen quicker or
your muscles fast or whatever it might
be
um you know i i think this just like
is some 1950s 1960s type [ __ ] that's
been carried over obviously there's like
a super racist history of
enforcing stuff like this and everyone
said this but like it's just so
silly every human being knows that
smoking marijuana does not make you
run faster you could maybe say it's a
performance enhancing drug if you're
competing in a creative space and you're
doing like
expressionist paintings or working on
improvisational music with your friends
or starting a jam band
sure it might enhance that performance
um but it's really ridiculous and you
know like some other sports have gone
through this like the nba recently for
the most part i'm pretty sure
um they stopped testing for that so like
if you're an nba player and you're in a
state
where that's legal it doesn't matter
because you're an adult
and it's legal in the place that you're
in um
it just makes me so mad and it's i just
and the when people say rules are rules
it's this weird i'm going to get a
little meta here
like theological attitude where people
have a thing built into their brains
where like we need gods to tell us what
to do and have these internal structures
to tell us how to live
so our human like brain hears rules and
we're like the rules are good i need the
rules
forgetting that they're just created by
a group of 10
largely [ __ ] in a room someplace to
enforce and like control the lives of
others so like the whole rules or rules
discourse i just hate so much
i'll stop brandon helen what do you
think about this one
i mean we're all on the same page here
like this is i think the decision to
exclude
you know to exclude her from the
olympics is dumb
and i think team usa is going to you
know regret it i'm
i guess i just don't so i was i
appreciate survey that you pointed out
like
why this happened because i could not um
you know i couldn't find this morning
um anything that was really clear as far
as like why
they decided that you know even though
the 30 day ban was over that they
weren't going to
let her back you know onto the relay
team and you said it was because
she they had already informed the people
who were going to be on the team that
they had been and they didn't want to
revoke those positions
yeah okay that's like fair right do we
feel that that's reasonable
to me that's that's fair that's the only
reasonable explanation that i could
really think of but i'm curious
well i'm curious as to like i was
because i was kind of pondering you know
why this might be the case
um but it sounds like you know there's
the explanation i was wondering if it
might have something to do with
you know they mentioned credibility um
as far as you know saying hey we can't
make an exception for this person and
that kind of thing which
doesn't fly with me because i think
there's um you know there's this great
2017 piece from box that talks about how
you know doping is
in all of these you know gray area ways
is super common among
you know um professional professional
athletes and these
you know who are you know at that elite
level because
the difference in winning and losing is
you know by seconds right so you have to
enhance your performance so much that
um it's just you you have to go to the
superhuman means to do
it um that so
so you know for them to be you know
disqualifying her on the basis of
after her ban is over on the basis of a
a drug that
we have absolutely no research
whatsoever that says well okay i think
there was like one paper that some
physician mentioned that said maybe
marijuana could enhance your ability to
you know uh to take part in in a sport
like sprinting can't even remember what
the paper was but it was the evidence
was
just shockingly weak for something like
this and so it's just ridiculous common
sense tells you you know
it's it's a sedative you're not going to
run faster because you smoke weed
i never have and so i don't you know i
like like what um so i think
that's uh yeah it seems super silly but
um
i mean i think maybe hopefully what'll
come out of this is that um
you know we re-evaluate the rules and we
look at
you know these the the way also i think
that something else i think is super
important here is
and just is mind-blowing to me is that
why was this
reporter the one breaking the news to
her that her her mother had died
like what yeah that was really hard to
hear and that's what happened and i can
imagine
that she knows that it's a banned
substance it's not a shock but
when you are in that frame of mind and
somebody tells you that when you're not
expecting it all you're going to make
you're going to make decisions that you
wouldn't normally make and she's been
very apologetic and saying that she's
made a mistake but holy [ __ ] what's
wrong with that reporter
yeah i just yeah everything
all the elements about this and the
dominoes that fell are so weird and
it is just like so annoying too that if
you know if someone
found out tragic news and we knew that
they had to take like
a xanax or a klonopin or something like
that to alleviate anxiety or something
or temporarily be on some sort of
antidepressant we would say well of
course
those are substances that have been
medically proven to help alleviate those
things
well in the exact same way cannabis has
been proven
to alleviate anxiety in some people and
to help calm nerves and dealing with all
types of mental health things which is
why it is like
a legal substance in many places and
used for many positive
purposes so it's just it's just a few it
seems like another example
and i'll say you know this is this apt
to say as we have our science friend
here
another example where society and
legislative bodies that have an
influence in society continue to ignore
scientific fact and research for the
sake of enforcing ideologies from a
bygone era that largely
you know affect people from certain
communities
i just can't think of a good reason they
do this i agree and this
argument that these are the rules and
rules or rules there was also a time in
our history when rules
would say that some member some humans
were not as
valuable as others like when you could
go kill people like i don't understand
this whole like rules or rules you could
change the rules
just because something's written doesn't
mean that it's okay yeah well i have a
question for both of you how has this
affected the way
you feel about the olympics in general
because i i mean i would be lying if i
didn't say it's
because i'm like you serbia i love the
olympics i've taken time off work to
watch them before
this is making me not excited and kind
of bummed about the whole enterprise how
are y'all feeling
i agree i i
i have felt for a while that i'm
uncomfortable with a lot of the
decisions made by the olympic committee
um i know that it's super corrupt i hate
the way they
you know host cities deal with a lot of
the economic fallout as a result of
hosting the olympics um
i think there are a lot of problems um
and then now that it's like affecting
the athletes as well there was another
runner too
i think that was disqualified last year
or something because her testosterone
levels were
were too high and they said that she was
masculine or something like that
um so like things like that really
bother me
um and it does take away from like that
spirit and magic of
of the world coming together and being
able to see people
and um compete in something that they
love
i i like that spirit of the olympics i
wish that we could just focus more on
that and
not get bogged down so much in these
arbitrary rules
definitely helen are you are you less
excited to decorate your home for the
olympics as you normally do every
oh no two years i guess yeah no
i mean i'm not as uh you know i'm not as
olympics obsessed as the two of you are
it sounds like
but um i do really appreciate them no
but i i
yeah right maybe i don't know but i
appreciate them for for what they are
especially is
you know i really like the idea of of
every you know kind of coming together
and every but you know
around the world and all of us
participating in this one thing that bun
you know
bonds us all is athletics in that sense
and
i think that um i was really stoked to
see her perform
i mean she's an incredible runner so
good and to
feel like you know that it's it's kind
of like well
because of this dumb thing that really
is
is uh you know comes off the back of
these you know antiquated rules that
desperately need overhauling
that because she isn't going to to
compete because of this it just
feels like yeah it's a huge bummer it's
a huge loss it's a huge loss for the us
team and i think that's
that you know just and this kind of puts
another pox on an already very sketchy
and
weird seeming olympics um john oliver's
show last week tonight that a really
good segment on the olympics i think
last week or the week before
and i i never i never knew until this
point that like for example right now
japan and the city of tokyo don't have
the authority to cancel the olympics
even though things are really bad over
there and like 10
of the population is vaccinated they're
currently in like a pretty elevated
state of lockdown in the city
because when you sign a contract with
the ioc they have to be the ones who
call it
and if japan or the city of tokyo
decided that for their country it was a
good thing to cancel it
they would have huge financial and legal
liability um
and and yeah just you know if anyone
wants to look into the history of the
olympics and what it does to a city it's
something you should never want in your
city
there's you know currently act an
activist group in l.a called no olympics
that's actively fighting against the
olympics coming here in a little bit
because of
the devastation it normally causes to
especially the most vulnerable people in
any city so
sorry to bum anyone out the olympics
might be bad even though they're fun
they might be bad so i'm sure we'll have
some more olympic discussion as it gets
closer because
sadly it seems like this one's going to
be a [ __ ] show
yeah and i was so disappointed because
when they selected
tokyo as the host city years ago and
then when we had
um like five years ago when they did
like the preview at the closing
ceremonies at the last summer olympics i
was like ah
this is gonna be amazing and now it just
seems like it's horrible
yeah not excited about that but
um so something else that's going on in
society that involves
competition between people from
different culture and backgrounds
is generational clashes we've already
referenced it on this episode
um and i saw some stuff going around on
twitter i know helen's doing the
research here
um some new stuff has been popping off
on tick tock
some some memes and videos that some
people might find charming that other
people have said make them want to like
throw their devices in a lake and move
into a cave and never look at anything
again
pop it off on tick tock so helen um tell
us what's going on with the
the burgeoning generational war on tick
tock and social media
all right so this has been going on for
a while
anybody who follows um you know i guess
follows generational wars but follows
culture more largely probably knows
about the whole
you know middle versus side part fiasco
the fact that skinny jeans were
cancelled
um all of these uh you know kinds of um
ridiculous things that uh kind of that
came about because um
basically millennials saw that gen z was
[ __ ] talking them
on tick tock they got mad and they
decided to take to their
favorite platform to spew their opinions
twitter to
whine about it um but that's my personal
take on if you can't tell so
um since then there have been a number
of musicals
uh yes musicals that have come out of of
this um
out of this uh conflict and um
the latest one popped up a few days ago
um it went viral on twitter
uh tv writer eli wilson pelton who i
think he writes for
insecure um on hbo high fidelity on hulu
a couple other shows
yeah he posted he posted a uh
a video of this or this tick tock rather
with the
with the caption um this makes me
physically ill um
and i i don't know if we can watch the
clip i did write a brief synopsis can we
can we play the clip on here i think we
talked
if i did not send it in we are now
playing the clip so
um we we can post it to social media um
later today and then we can make sure
we'll do our twitter handles at the end
so
one or all of us can post this clip so
people can see it but i think people if
you want to find this it's pretty
pretty easily searchable look for this
makes me physically ill
yes that'll get you to it and i did
write a really brief synopsis that i'm
gonna i'm gonna read
real real quick so pretty much this is
an original tiktok micro musical by
micro musical powerhouse pixel playhouse
which is a um
a a real company that is um they do they
do
uh micro musicals on twitch and on
um other places around social media
personally i think it's pretty dope but
that's just me
um but this one seeks to illuminate the
plight of zillennials which is basically
anyone who's born between the years 1994
and 2000
according to i did not know this was a
thing yes it's a thing this is a thing
so
i mean and this is this is buzzfeed's
definition which i guess is kind of like
the source of truth for
these uh sorts of questions so um
the plot effectively is that we have two
panicked in-betweeners in the throes of
an identity crisis are goaded by dueling
choruses of genzirs and millennials to
join their ranks
as they sling generational jabs and
one-up each other with their merits
which are you know tick-tock
dancing skills dvds middle parts uh
crushing student loan debt i think they
reference there too until one of our
zillenial heroes brings them together
with something everyone can agree on
which is the office so i think at the
end the
one of the middle yeah so so in the end
uh one of them says you know like
question asks you know like jim and pam
everybody's like oh my god i love the
office so watch it you know
um i was uh i don't know what do you
which would you guys um what's your
opinion on tick tock musicals
are or uh whether or not this is um you
know a sub genre that you feel strongly
about but
frankly i was you know i mean a lot of
people were talking about how this is
just um
another sign of the end times and i kind
of thought it was
uh it was rather rather nice a little
it's it's silly
you know the content itself is silly but
um i like that you know people are
making musicals i love musicals so
um but anyway so
in my opinion on one hand this is you
know both kind of awesome like i said
but it also extremely cringe but
really only because of you know the
subject matter like i said and i think
um
i kind of want to overthink this video
for a second here which is like
you know please do yeah so from my
perspective
this is kind of a microcosm for how how
inner gender relational
relationships are playing out on the
internet as a whole and they've gotten a
lot of attention
in in the media for being you know for
the
like i said the jabs that are slung back
and forth the fact that you know
millennials feel the need to
defend themselves when gen z makes fun
of their you know obsession with harry
potter or whatever right
and um you know the fact that really it
feels like most of the time the ones who
are taking this
most seriously are millennials um but
what i think is so intriguing is that
this is
you know within with thanks to the dawn
of the internet right like or thanks to
the the
the fact that everybody's online we are
largely occupying the same spaces
with people from other generations in a
way that we never have before
and that gives us an opportunity to you
know just
like you know lob insults at each other
right but
also if you spend you know a lot of time
on reddit or quora or
you know forums where there's a lot of
anonymity or
either that or there's a lot of
intermixing between generations you find
that
really what what's you know that people
are leveraging the fact that they can
connect with
you know strangers um online who are you
know
not from their generation to seek out
advice be it you know
how do i um decide whether or not i
should have kids do
or how do i say for instance you know
decide what to do with my life or
whether or not you know this career path
is good for me
in a way that wasn't really possible
before right like before you know you
had a certain
small group of people who were from not
from your generation
that you could interact with to ask
questions about life
now we have you know billions of
strangers all around the world who we
can connect with
you know quite easily and you know get
advice from to figure out
you know what how to really be able to
you know make good decisions and
um how to just you know think critically
about you know the paths you know that
that lay in front of us
and um i maybe i'm just like looking for
little bits of optimism
and you know in kind of the chaos that
is the world but i think that that's
kind of nice
and so um yeah well can i ask a question
to i guess both of you and
and i love your general read on this
that musicals are fun maybe the topic of
this one is silly
i i have a sense of do we think that
like this cultural divide
is is has been heightened precisely
because there isn't a divide
and what i mean by that is like we all
consume the same culture we have a
monoculture that exists on the internet
and everyone that is next on the
internet sees watches
reads so much so many of the same things
that i know i don't feel weird like i
have colleagues
it wisecrack i won't say their names who
are definitely in that generation you
describe
and i don't feel like i'm talking to
different people we like a lot of the
same things we have a lot of the same
commonalities
and i worry that the desire for this
divide is largely just produced by
millennials who want to think that
they're special
and as anyone who listens to this
podcast regularly knows i'm i have class
solidarity with gen z
and when the culture work comes i will
kill my own for their cause sign me up
i'm ready to go
um but is this just like a made-up thing
by millennials who are
too precious when in fact we consume a
lot of the same things kind of
which is i think pointed out by the
office thing it's like of course because
everyone watches the same stuff but i
don't know serbia what do you think in
the
in our increasing check-ins with the
generational divide war
i don't really see it as a war or that
big of a difference as you were saying
i mean to me it just sort of feels like
millennials are reaching that
that that like natural phase
of life where you kind of get out of
touch
a little bit with with what the cool
thing is
um but that's just natural i mean that
just happens it took me a while to
figure out what tic-tac was not a while
i mean but i just didn't know
about tick-tock and was like oh what's
this um
i just think it's like a natural change
in like a life cycle
but i don't see it as like a war or
anything weird it's just
yeah why do you all think people are
precious about it then like i'm
wondering not to ask us to psychoanalyze
people we don't know or
a generational cross-section but i
wonder like why
because i think about this tick tock i
saw a few weeks ago or maybe a few
months ago it's really horrible
where this this woman um says something
like
your generation has safe spaces mine had
mosh pits we are not the same and it was
like the dumbest thing ever and everyone
from like hardcore music culture
pointed out that the whole point of a
mosh pit is to provide like a
safe space for a certain sort of
activity but it just made me think like
why do you
care like why are you so mad why are you
defending your like washed
generation and not letting people like
be who they are but i don't know where
do you all think that comes from why do
people
want to like have these fights
i mean the as well you know
they've always done it's just they're
obviously they're just bitter i think
there's a lot of bitterness about the
fact that you're no longer you know
the cool young thing that everybody's
talking about and you know the media
reinforces that with the way that they
portray aging the way that they portray
people as being out of touch and we are
and there's also just the shame that
comes with being out of touch like
serbia said there's like a natural
um you know decline in in touchiness as
you get older because
what we see as in touch is you know
that's youth culture you know right
that's that is what it means to be in
touch is like
you know in with with um
with the youth i guess and so i think um
that's always played out that's always
been a thing right but
thanks to the internet uh you know to to
one of the you know the darker aspect of
it is obviously
it's a place where we can easily
perpetuate rage and where we can you
know
just kind of um you know just mouth off
about whatever it is that's that's
bothering us
and if it's this the younger generation
is
you know making fun of my like love of
doggos or whatever
like that's uh something that people
want to you know
that's that's that's right for for
frustration and venting i guess
so i think it's an internet culture
thing too i wish everyone could like
learn that it's okay to not be
cool and you get your your young for a
bit and then you get older and the
my favorite people who are older are
people that are just chill
and don't think about this stuff and are
happy where they are in life
not that this is like advice corner to
anyone but it's just like
who cares like what you like don't be
bitter or jealous
be friends with people of all different
ages i mean within reason and
legality but yeah i don't know who wants
time for that [ __ ]
like i don't know i don't have time to
be like
like annoyed and upset and [ __ ] about
like stuff like that like i have real
problems that i need to be figuring out
like the fact that i'm
one person covering eight roles at my
company like that is occupying my
thoughts
not um like what's going on on tick tock
i'd like to have that life where like i
could just sit around and be
enraged by the younger generations yeah
yeah well you know speaking of
kind of stepping back from having a
stressful life with eight roles and lots
to do
and just wanting to chill and accept
one's age
we have a special segment with alec who
can't be here right now because he's
traveling
but we pre-recorded something we're
talking with alec about something going
on
in his life and we're gonna play that
now
so we'll we'll be back live after the
segment hang out in the chat if you're
here
but now serbia and i have a little chat
with alec
about his generational gap and growth
okay guys so we're doing a special
segment today
because the godfather of culture binge
the fourth
meal of wisecrack i'm gonna go out comes
the bathroom and grabbing that
announcement to make so alec take it
away
the floor and the show is yours uh i'm
leaving
uh i won't be on culture binge for the
foreseeable future
uh because i'm quitting my job to go
hiking
that is not a joke um
so won't be a part of wisecrack uh
won't be on culture binge for the
foreseeable future and by that i just
mean you know
after i'm done traveling i'd love to
maybe pop in now and then i love you all
uh
you know i love everyone's support all
your emails your
doofy names for us what kind of uh
you know drugs we would be that kind of
stuff uh it's been amazing and i'd love
to
you know not completely distance myself
from that
okay well that said um thanks this has
been culture binge we're done with alec
forever now
for serving i'm kidding i'm kidding um
well alex first of all i don't know how
you're feeling about this derby i know
one thing i'm feeling for sure is
i hope at some point in my life i get to
say the the sentence i'm quitting my job
to go hiking
yes yeah that absolutely rules
so we're happy about that we're sad that
you're leaving um
question who were you did you all both
start culture binge at the same time was
one of you first
it was i don't
sir do you remember i think you and
jared did it the first episode together
and then i came in on the second episode
yeah the original idea is like let's try
out some different people whatever and
then we had serbians like oh she's great
we're gonna we're gonna keep her on
yeah wow that's amazing so what was the
what was it like the first time you met
alex
i imagine it was was it on you know a
skype screen just like we are now
yeah i've never met alec in person it
was just on skype
during that episode in fact um
i had known jared before because we've
met in person and then
we did uh thug notes together but um
this was my first time chatting with
alec and i was like oh he's so nice
how come i haven't met him before
because i'd been working with wisecrack
for a few years previously um
but yeah he was just so nice and very
easy to talk to felt very natural
to talk to him the funny thing with
meeting elegant person is he's just
taller than you think he's going to be
yeah um for anyone who is a regular
listener or watcher and this is a weird
thing to say i think sometimes people
have it have an
energy related to height and i don't
want to say alec has like short energy
and i'm not saying short energy is bad
it's not i think alec has like an
energy of an affable you know slightly
above average height person
but then you meet him and he has has the
height of a
small but functional nba point guard
yeah
so um you know we'd say he's probably
about the same height as damien lillard
for any portland trailblazers fans out
there don't know who that is but
he's a very good basketball player
because i remember the first time i met
alec
in person i'm just thinking like oh he's
just tall and i was like intimidated
i wanted to be the tall one you know
i don't remember how tall are you in my
mind you're short
yeah the crazy thing is yeah you think
i'm short and i'm i'm i'm a solid six
so i think you got what two inches on me
four
four inches man c see i still think he's
short for that um
so he's a tall man we're going to miss
him a lot let me ask you this alex what
is
well how how long have you worked at
wisecrack
including times that you were doing any
any freelancer contributing stuff
oh god uh five
five years i want to say wow is this the
longest you ever worked at one
job yeah my other job i worked for for
two years and then quit to work at
wisecrack
interestingly enough i was like hey i'm
quitting my job jacob do you want to
hire me and he said
yes but let me see if i can do that so
everyone fall out
longer than five years i feel like it
was 2016.
i think it was sooner than that because
i started working with wisecrack in 2014
i think i'm gonna i'm
gonna go with my [ __ ] like nobody to
offend me on linkedin i swear to god
everyone find alec on linkedin expand
the network
send him a really long message um
yeah linkedin's great it's the only way
that i know how long i've worked at
places
all right well well while alec is
looking that up
june 2015 [ __ ] so six years
wow wow serbia have you ever worked in
any place for six years
wisecrack i mean i haven't worked here
full time but
yeah the only one that's like the
longest place i've never worked anyplace
for six full years i've never had the
level of
commitment and attachment that alec does
to to wisecrack alec is
is wisecrack your longest relationship
or have you as your romantic
relationship
my romantic relationship is pre-dates
wisecrack so i've been
i've been in that longer okay so there's
one thing so wisecrack is my second
longest
romantic relationship well how about
this in six years
and listen we're not gonna get corny
right here you're leaving this is it's a
job you're quitting your job to go
hiking we're happy for you however
i got to ask you some questions what do
you think is that when you look back on
your time at wisecrack
on on the podcast on the videos on the
meetings with corporate sponsors all
these things
what's the thing you're proudest of that
you're gonna look back on and be like
i feel good that i that i did this thing
that i wrote this thing that i
contributed to this thing
is is there one or a few examples you
can think of in that realm
yeah i think it's probably specific
videos the one i always go to
uh it's just muscle memory is i didn't
write this but deeper dumb nick cage is
like one of the best episodes we've ever
put out everyone should go watch it it
was written by amanda shurker it's
incredible
um but yeah i think there's a like a
handful of episodes that either i've
worked on or
um you know i've written myself that i
think i'm glad that they are
in the internet and will continue to be
in the internet like philosophy of house
of cards or
uh you know the deadpool videos are
older ones or more recently like uh
why are smart people so dumb and the
myth of genius i thought were really
great episodes i'm just glad that i
could uh
contribute that to the pop cult pop
culture zeitgeist
yeah i agree i think some of the best
things you've ever done for the channel
are in that realm of the wire smart
people dumb and
and and kind of know but i think you're
like you've you've really done such a
good job and some of the stuff that you
made i
i love so much are the things that take
a kind of simple
or not even surface level but like more
like pop culture level question
and dig into it in a really deep way and
i think that's great and embodies
the best of what wisecrack can do so i
know that
in your absence that's sort of the uh
the mark we will be
looking at um i have another question in
serbia jump in whenever but what do you
really think about slaps and chaps as a
segment
i i don't know i mean
here's the thing i listen to other
podcasts and there's a lot of chitchat
at the beginning and it's a joke it's
just like
you're you got to listen to like 10
minutes of just unstructured
conversation to get to the actual point
and i thought with slaps and chaps it's
contained it's not going to get there
and so to that that point i like it and
i think it's a cool way for us to
to rep you know what we're watching what
we're eating etc etc
um but yeah i i
this is more of an anxiety rather than a
feeling my anxiety is
it's it's those 10 minutes of those
dudes just talking for 10 minutes on
every other podcast that i find so
annoying
maybe it would be nice if we did it at
the end of the episode do it
you can i'm not the boss anymore you
could do whatev
yeah well listen this is spoilers these
things are on the table
ladies and gentlemen things are on the
table things might change so i needed to
get alex opinions way out the door
serbian i'll put you on the spot do you
have any questions or thoughts for alec
as we have our exit interview who do you
think you are how dare you
what are you going to miss the most from
your time here at wisecrack probably
writing scripts
like or just researching them you know
even um
that but just to
make a connection to like a weird thing
in a tv show
and then you know read a [ __ ] ton of
books and put it in a script and spend
too much time on it
is probably one of the most fulfilling
things about the job and i i think the
second most
just like working with people who have
really good ideas and sort of like
helping them get the best version of
that idea like on
paper and in video form uh those two
things that's a little bit of a cheat
to say too wow i like that so what's the
thing you worked on at wisecrack you're
most embarrassed of the video that might
pop up that you're like why did i do
that why did we do that
uh yeah
you know
i think in my mind the one i'm thinking
of is the thing that the fans hate the
most but do i actually hate it i don't
know the thing that people hate the most
is the philosophy of dark souls video
but it was fine i don't you know yeah
you know i'm not
i'm not i'm just trying to uh i don't
know
to be honest like it's not a specific
thing but even looking at the old
older videos like some of the first
stuff i had written
and the things i've probably done the
the best
like on all sides we were just like
worse at what we do at the time and this
isn't throwing shade but like i was not
as good of a writer
so like things are like unstructured and
sentences are awkward
um you know jared at that time was not
as good of a performer as he came to be
and so like i'll watch like the original
philosophy rick and morty video and be
like oh like why is this here like why'd
i do it that way
and i think that's the only embarrassing
thing but i think that's part of the
the artistic process to hate the things
you've previously made that you're
better at now
that's totally fair that's totally fair
what would you say to people in the
comments that
um complain about how they have to watch
ads on youtube
gotta pay the bills somehow man i don't
know
they could become they could become
patrons if this were a solely
patron only you know if we were able to
pay everyone salaries like yeah that's
the dream but
um until then
yeah so you mentioned earlier that you
are
going to hike how else are you planning
to spend your your time off
basically driving around going to
national parks camping
um and then staying with friends at
various places
seeing family um that's basically it
it's gonna be hanging out and hiking
uh there will be zero work and if i end
up working even on
like a pet project like i've been
editing a nick cage compilation i
i just i just can't i can't do that i
can't
i need to do nothing at least for two
months yeah
are you guys giving up your place uh
no i don't think so sorry getting into
personal real estate
i know i was it's rent stabilized
they're gonna pull me out when i'm dead
don't leave it yet don't you can't leave
that um what's a better city for vegans
los angeles or new york
oh i don't it actually might be los
angeles only because
there's the overlap of like not only do
you have like the vegan for ethical
reasons you also just have like the
woo-woo health food
and you know there's vegan food for both
of those markets where i think new york
has less woo-woo
but plenty of people who are vegan for
ethical reasons
um so i feel like la's just way
better at catering to like every
restaurant has like 18 million
gluten-free options vegan options
carb free etc yeah
that's great um final formal question
for me
how good does it feel the day that you
quit your job on a scale from zero to
bathing in a bath full of mdma uh like
the day you give your notice or the date
because i i won't know the um
i mean well i guess yeah i guess there's
two there's one you don't know but
i mean how good does it feel like send
the email or have the call where you're
just like
oppermann out you know it's always you
feel like it's gonna feel like taking a
bath in mdma but it's always like
disappointing in a weird way like the
you know the reaction is not like what
you expected or
they're just like okay like whatever
um yeah thanks for working you want him
to cry and like beg you to stay
uh no but yes yeah like yeah well it's
like in a breakup if i
i was like breaking up with someone and
you like work up to it
you don't want them to be like you know
what i get that yeah
yeah yeah like good luck in the future
uh it's been great dating you
um let me know if you need anything uh
that's not cathartic
you want them to be like why
that's the one thing i learned is that
like companies will just keep on
chugging
doesn't matter how important they you
think you are
they'll just keep moving forward um but
we'll miss you though
and i was sad when you told me i wanted
to be like no
don't go stay here but you didn't serbia
and you stole that guitar so
i'm kidding wow well
two things let's do this before we go
first and let's all do this um you know
leaving a job and moving on is is a lot
like leaving any relationship
so let's all give her a quick break of
advice sergey if you're
if a listener has to break up with
someone soon how should they do it
what's the best way to break up with
someone
oh my god please don't ask me this i'm
still
trying to get over the breakup of last
year um
if you have to break up with someone
just be kind um
and uh show empathy and uh
just be as mature as possible don't say
like negative things
um it's just best to be an adult and say
this isn't working out
let's try to be friends if not then
let's wish each other well
move on yeah alec how do that's really
great survey it's a truly good advice
alex how should people break up
yeah keep keep it calm you know uh you
might want to give a laundry list of
everything wrong with the other person
but then that person will remember those
things and if they run into you 10 years
from now
they'll like hold in front of your face
somehow hold in front of your face
yeah what's the whatever you know what
i'm saying yeah throw it throw it
through it throw it in your face yeah
yeah that's good yeah i would say you
know don't show up with the person
you've been dating behind their back
at the applebee's you're meeting them at
to break up with them sounds awesome
yeah but i think think long term you
know think about like break up with
someone in such a way that when you run
into them in 10 years
they'll be like hey what's up how are
you doing like hope things are good
let's hang out like i still think you
sometimes like when i'm with my husband
like i say your name like that type of
thing so
um yeah but i think the kindness the
empathy the niceness
all that stuff is good the last thing i
want to do is
um we have we have a bunch more emails
telling us what we are in a category of
something um sadly alex not get to
experience all of these
i do want to say that we got an email
recently that lets us know which
female rappers we are okay um
i'll quickly say serbian mind without
the descriptions and maybe we can read
this on the next full episode serbia
gets to be nicki minaj
which is great okay um i got to be cardi
b
very excited about that especially i
want to be cardi b the person gave the
example of cardi and bernie together
so i was like they get it alec is doja
cat
you know you once said you used to be a
bit of a troll on the internet when you
were younger and that's
very much doji cat also seems like
someone who would sit back
and chill with like the with to chill
with and having only heard both of your
voices first
was surprised to learn that both of you
look like lol
but i keep thinking back to the time
burns said you would be miranda cynthia
nixon from sex in the city
and i don't know if dojo matches that
vibe
so i wanted you to have that on your way
out the door um the last
listener comparing you to a thing you
get to be doja cat cause you're a troll
and you look different than how you
sound
i haven't read enough about doja cat to
know how afraid of this comparison i
should be
i know i know there's like some stuff in
the background about like her saying
some [ __ ] that i probably don't think is
cool
i will say without full knowledge of
that [ __ ] on my cow is an incredible
song
yeah i played it for some friends like
two weeks ago it's a good it was a good
song and to be fair
this listener also said my other thought
was one of the older rappers like missy
elliott
who's great or smaller lesser known
rapper lil sims lil sims
i don't know but rapper she rips real
hard everyone should listen to the
little sims um
but i wanted to leave you with that i
guess we'll give the final word to you
alec what is you know this this podcast
has been
for you an adventure into the cultural
zeitgeist we have looked at
surface level and pop cultural things
and tried to find
some meaning in them to understand
something about society but ultimately
to understand something about ourselves
so
i don't know what's the what's a piece
of advice or a piece of pop culture you
think
would be important to people leave
everyone with something before
you you come back because there's so
much pressure
you know because what we're going to see
you down the road
leave us with something uh i don't know
man
read books they're great
read books they're great i couldn't say
it better than that that's my life alex
yeah thank you again we're gonna miss
the [ __ ] out of you and we're excited
for you to come back soon um
and in the meantime we're gonna have
some fun new friends on and see how that
goes their beards aren't gonna be as
good as yours but you know we'll try to
have fun with it
maybe maybe they can take some biotin or
something really
beef it up
okay great well thank you for that um
and nothing else to say but we'll see
you down the road buddy thanks everyone
bye
well there you have that folks um and
our main takeaway from all of that the
most important thing you just heard
there is if you can
quit your job go hiking go scuba diving
do something else
for those of us who can't quit our jobs
um so shout out to that
so we got to get into it we we only have
a little bit of time left for going
along but we appreciate you for sticking
with us
it's mail bag time friends so we love to
hear from you we love to talk to you you
already know this but you can write us
at culture binge wisecrack.com that's
culture binge at wisecorrect.co
and you can call us at two one three
five three four eight eight zero seven
that is two
one three five three four eight eight
zero seven
and you know per helen's topic uh do an
audio musical and send it to us and
we'll play it that would be awesome
now we got a couple longer emails real
quick and i might condense some stuff
here but they're both really great
um this is from joe and this is related
to our last topic
sorry last episode um joe says this
first of all serbia's unabashed comments
on the plight of the white man really
tickled me and i couldn't help but laugh
i believe she was correct in calling out
the links we go to to protect the
feelings
or comfort of white people as a driving
force behind the legislator being pushed
through on the topic i am biracial and
have three adults or siblings
and when you get us all together in a
room we can definitely dive into some
deep topics such as race systematic
racism
and just about and just trying to
navigate spaces as persons of color
multiracial people
my mom however is often trying to change
the subject from those things to
something more
light-hearted and when asked why she
always says that she wants to
that it makes her uncomfortable or she
doesn't have anything to say on the
topic
now to be clear this person says they
they love their mom
many times so i'm going to skip the part
where they talk about how much they love
their mom
joe loves his mom joe's mom if you're
listening lots of love
but joe then says we can't begin the
process of fixing things unless we
properly identify sources and educate
people on them sure kids might be too
young to grasp it fully
but i don't think planting those seeds
is necessarily a bad thing quite the
opposite really
having teachers scared of losing their
jobs just because of saying something
that could be constructed as critical
race theory is definitely not the answer
it's just censorship love you guys and
keep the amazing content coming
joe and joe also says he appreciated on
the advice about how to
uh comfort a friend whose family member
had died recently so that was on the
critical race theory topic we talked
about last time
serbia any comments on this person who
wrote an email talking about the fact
that you're both smart and funny
oh that was so lovely i really like this
email um i think
so my thought when i when i read this
email is that
is it possible that his mom is
uncomfortable with the topic because i
believe
his mom is white and i wonder if maybe
she
maybe it's possible maybe she feels
guilty or she feels
uncomfortable talking about it because
she can't
identify with the situations that her um
children go through so maybe that's why
she's trying to like
move the topic along not because she
doesn't um empathize but because
maybe there's like a deep rooted
discomfort there
because it sounds like his mom's lovely
yeah so that's the only
thing that i could think of that's the
only reason why sometimes i try to move
topics along sometimes because i
feel uncomfortable for one reason or
another and i i feel like i'm
i'm the odd woman out who can't offer
offer anything that it might might feel
empty
if i were to to share an opinion about
something
yeah i'm going to keep my mouth shut as
a just some dumb white dude but yes
thank you that sounds good and i agree
with joe's point though like we got to
have hard conversations to make stuff
better
um quickly going to another email just
we got to wrap up soon our friend megan
roach wrote an email and just shouts to
megan in general she writes really good
thoughtful
emails um and often we just don't get
into on the show because they're like
really interesting essays um but megan
and this is also on the
critical race theory topic and i'll hit
a few of the points she makes here
but she says i think the topic that has
made most people wary
of critical race theories discussions
around intent critical race theory seems
to be very consequentialist in making a
moral value judgment it does not matter
if
intent is present because the systematic
structures are designed to
self-perpetuate
slavoy jijek's book of violence did a
really great analysis of this the
argument is that if the results
consequences are functionally
indistinguishable
indistinguishable between
well-intentioned and non-racist
and male intended deliberately racist
people then it doesn't matter because
the harm
caused is the same skipping ahead to the
end of her email she says because point
blank
i don't want people to not be racist or
sexist because they're afraid of being
called a bad
person um oh which
sorry um i want people in society that i
occupy to be politically self-actualized
and aware of their unique
positionality of intersectional power
and use that self-awareness to navigate
their lives
and to make informed choices in their
decision making so
to kind of sum up a very interesting
long email megan saying here that the
worry about critical race theory
shouldn't be
people act a type of way because we're
afraid of being bad or afraid of being
cancelled
this kind of goes with joe's email um
people should be
thinking through these things in terms
of intent and we need a society where
people
are anti-racist and anti-sexist not
because they
don't want people to not like them
because they actively want to be
anti-racist and anti-sexist so
i assume no one's gonna fight back on
that in this game
[Laughter]
yeah i really like
everyone every time i see one of those
in my inbox i'm like
let's go very thoughtful and we
appreciate it um
and you know this is this is true for
megan and true for a lot of our friends
just know if
if we're ever not reading your emails on
air sometimes it's because they're
really good and long
um and we just don't have time to get
into that but we read all of the emails
we listen to all the voicemails
you all are the best and we love you and
just so you know in light of the last
segment
um that we had with alec we're still
here we're gonna have some awesome new
friends on we're gonna bring some cool
voices onto the show
people like helen maybe not as good and
smart as helen but they'll try their
best
um but know that we're still gonna be
bringing heat for y'all and once again
hit us up at culturebindingwisecrack.com
call us at 213-534-8807
now before we finish helen until you are
back
on this podcast where can people find
you in the meantime
digitally please don't give them your
address or phone number
yeah for sure not gonna give that out um
let's
you can find me on instagram actually
i'm a little bit more active there than
on twitter
um unless i'm raging about something i
guess my
just find me at flourish which is my
last name so f-l-o-e-r-s-h
amazing serbia you know people probably
know this if they're culture binge heads
but um where can people find you
on the generationally unified internet
twitter siripatel22 awesome
as always i am michael o burns on
twitter
instagram and other things not other
things just those two
um so thanks again to helen flores for
being here really appreciated it and we
hope
we hope you'll come back sometime
just kidding yeah thank you thank you
awesome
yeah no worries thank you so much and
we'll be back in two weeks
we'll have anot another fun friend there
with us so i have a great couple weeks
in the meantime this has been cult
revenge
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you